good afternoon my name is Paul Dodson
director of strategy performance and
governance at Molden District Council
welcome to the first meeting of the hay
bridge base and parish council on the
7th of May 2020 the time is 12:30
I'm opening the meeting in the absence
of a chairman can I please ask all
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted and your video
feed off while you're not addressing the
meeting further introductory remarks
around the operation of remote meetings
will be covered by the chairman once
elected the first order of business is
to appoint a chairman can I ask
councilors present to unmute their
microphones turn on their video feed and
introduce themselves to the meeting in
an alphabetical order and once
introduced please mute your microphone
so starting with councilor Edwards
good morning my name is Michael Edwards
I'm a modern district counselor and a
huge Parish counselor thank you good
morning my name is councillor Brian
Harker and I am the one of the elected
councillors for hybrid yeast which
includes the hay breeze bass and ward
good morning my name is Jenny Shalimar
and I and caretaker of the huge basin
whilst we're in this increment period
okay thank you
could any councillor wishing to nominate
to the position of chairman please
unmute your microphone state your name
and the nomination
Thank You counselor Michael Edwards I
would like to nominate counselor Brian
Harker as chairman of a big basement
parish council thank you okay thank you
if any member wishes to second the
nomination please unmute your microphone
and state your name and yeah my name is
Jenny Shalimar and I would like to can't
sleep with foreigners okay thank you
very much in that case I declare
capsular haka appointed as chairman of
the Highbridge barish parish Highbridge
bass and parish council for the
remainder of the municipal year I will
now hand business over to the chairman
of the meeting thank you Paul
first item on the agenda is appointment
of a vice chair of the parish council
see ya good afternoon my name is council
Bernhardt and this is the first remote
meeting held under new regulations which
came into effect on the 4th of April in
response to the covert 19 situation
there are just a few housekeeping issues
to run through including our new working
practices which have been implemented
due to the pandemic and etic work for
this meeting first of all could I remind
everyone present in this meeting to
ensure your microphone remains muted and
your video feed off whilst you are not
addressing the meeting this will reduce
background noises and avoid any
unintentional disturbances this meeting
will be hosted remotely by compressing
software which will allow counselors or
members and the public to virtually
attend this meeting whilst being able to
protect themselves and others and
observe the government's lockdown
measures we may encounter some glitches
as afternoon so I hope that everyone
will bear with us as we get used to this
new way of working
we are streaming this mating live as
well as recording and being present in
this meeting you are giving your consent
to be recorded when speaking and
referring to the agenda please ensure
you reference the item number or
appendix when you that you are referring
to could also he sure could also ensure
that everyone is directly connected to a
power supply so that nobody talks out
during the short battery life next item
on the agenda is to point a
vice-chairman any counselor wishing to
nominate to the position of our Chairman
please unmute your microphone state your
name and nomination from the chair I
would nominate a counselor Shalimar to
be my vice chairman is that seconded yes
chairman our second met propose thank
you I therefore declare counselor
Shalimar appointed as vice chairman of
the hybrid base of parish council for a
remainder and the immediate myth of the
municipal year now I ask other officers
taking part in this meeting to introduce
themselves starting with committee
services clogged good afternoon
Thank You chairman my name is Brianna
Casey committee services modern district
council and I'm Clark to the meeting
this afternoon and then the performance
and governance manager and hi I'm Cheryl
he's on the program his performance and
governance manager at London district
council thank you and finally but not
least the monitoring officer hello I'm
Simon Quelch
and I'm a solicitor employed by the mold
industry Council thank you
agenda item 3 - a
- mogul code of conduct in the same
terms of Malda district council as shown
on appendix B if anyone wishes to speak
to this origin please indicate it as
previously advised by unmuting your
microphone yes chairman
agreed right declarations of interest
and then he brought any council has an
interest to declare preach indicate as
previously advised I'll start with
myself I'm the member of the hybrid base
and parish council referendum team
counselor ed was have you any
declarations yes chairman non-pecuniary
as I remember parish council thank you
encounter Shalimar yes I'm also a member
of the hey [ __ ] Basin referendum team
okay that's there with the decoration to
it appointment of a Clark and proper
officer and responsible financial
officer of any council that wishes to
speak to this item please indicate as
previously and the Clark that has been
chosen by the members when we had a
meeting on last Tuesday with mr. John
Watson has everybody agree to that
appointment
yes German the read agreed great thank
you
therefore I confirmed the appointment of
John Watson of Clark and proper officer
and responsible financial officer for
the hey bridge bass and parish council
general item six delegation of all
decisions of a bridge basin Parish
Council to the Clark in consultation
with the Chairman or vice chairman
and other than budgetary issues which
are prohibited by section 101 of the
Local Government Act 1972 does anybody
wish to speak to this item any council
of wish to speak to this item
yes Jobin agreed counsel Shalimar do you
agree to the appointment of mr. Watson
asked Clark I do indeed
thank you so we've agreed that the
delegation of all decisions of hatred
Parrish basin Parish Council to the
clerk in consultation with the Chairman
and that's all agreed one thing we
didn't do where we when we were
appointed as chairman and vice-chairman
is to actually do we need mr. Quelch
do we need to read out the declaration
of acceptance of office know that no
chairman you don't need to do that no
all you need to do is just sign rap and
yeah just sign it I just want to make
sure we did that correctly and leave
that open great hole in what we've done
right agenda item 7 remote public and
attendants and participating in writing
as any councillor wishes to speak to
this item please say so now so we've got
one item we raised by electorate of hey
Bridge basin and that's mr. bill riches
and he is asked the following question
who are our councillors and how stroke
win were they appointed the same
questions apply to the other positions
during this current crisis why has this
process not being suspended
to allow for the do democratic
procedures to be followed mr. quartz
could you please answer that query
please yes thank you very much chairman
and we've obviously had a look at that
question and and thought about about it
and let me just find in fact I'll just
have to record because it hasn't I can't
find it on my on my chat button and in
short what happened is that hey Big
Basin Parish Council was was formed
under the reorganization order from the
1st of April at that time at the time
the organization order was made we had
no idea that was going to be this
pandemic and a lockdown that has come
with it the result of that is of course
the government has passed legislation
that has postponed the elections that we
had anticipated would take place to fill
the seven seats on hay bridge Basin
parish council and today in fact because
of that legislation now all elections
they're relevant have been postponed for
a year now
because hey bridge parish hey bridge
basin parish council is already an
entity and already has responsibilities
to govern the basin area it wouldn't be
able to act at all because it hasn't got
any councillors and because of the
legislation there would be nobody able
to act and no decisions could possibly
be made so things like clearing the bins
responding to planning applications
looking after the Daisy Meadow car park
all the matters that will relate to the
basin could no longer no no decisions
could be made on them and the District
Council though and legislation given
a number of years ago by the government
has powers to appoint individuals to the
position of chairman where we're in a
situation like this where a council
cannot operate and so in order that the
residents of hay bridge Basin Parish
Council have an effective governing
Parish Council in the interim prior to
elections becoming law for the council
has exercised its powers and appointed
the three of you to be councillors thank
you I think in the question they said
who are our counselors so I'll repeat
that the counselors are myself counselor
Brian Harker counselor Michael Edwards
and counselor Jenny Shalimar
they are the counselors appointed for
the ensuing municipal year and hopefully
there will be elections next May where a
full quota of seven councils will
hopefully be elected and then there's
full force of democracy will reign well
actually I could make what I give you
permanently chairman can I just make one
point on that if the restrictions
imposed by the government are relaxed
and although the legislation says that
all elections are postponed until May
the government may decide actually to
allow elections to take place earlier so
it's a possibility that this temporary
arrangement won't be for a year
depending on what the government permit
yes okay but in the absence of anything
else we are elected for the rest of the
municipal year unless the government
decide to have some elections in October
or we have been known to have a general
election in December so you never know
that's correct right has anybody else
got any items of
that I wish to raise that the users of
that general no we can't do that because
you can't have any other business an
annual or Saturday annual meeting so I
therefore now close the meeting and
counselors and officer advised not to
when to move any further discussions on
this format and please lead leading
properly